what is your favorite side thanksgiving
side not bread how boring is that like
vanilla ice cream when you have
thousands to choose what state is that
so i don't go to it
what about yours scalloped potatoes for
me i love those okay so that was rhode
island that's what
but for me a mashed potatoes because if
you get the right gravy
potatoes oh i don't do gravy
are you serious how are we friends
how are we from i just like it i like
that meat pure i don't do the gravy okay
all right well when you come over it's
gonna be easy
[Laughter]
we're gonna have an easy meal
well i guess i can do whatever we got
we're talking about all this food and
we're starving because we were talking
to kevin and chris earlier about the
food and it's not it's only four o'clock
all right live look outside love this
tower camp this is on top black mountain
from our our tower looking at the las
vegas strip when we get to sunset time
this is going to be gorgeous and now we
know sunsets an hour earlier now right
77 centennial hills along with sky
canyon aliante and spring valley that's
the popular number right now across the
valley 80 even for north las vegas 81
sunrise manor 80 for whitney ranch 76
henderson double sevens mountains edge
roads ranch included and uh 77 also for
anthem again i will always switch up
neighborhoods me and the whole weather
team will always switch up our
neighborhoods every weather cast so
nobody's left out 72 in union springs
prompt 74 82 in laflett satellite radar
shows just a band of clouds moving
overhead right now and then some
clearing but look at the thicker clouds
out here now what we're watching are two
systems this one and this one right here
this one is going to tap again into
another atmospheric river and what
that's going to do is send all that rain
into central portions of california okay
one to two inches of rain possible with
that might under flooding and ponding of
the roads for sure with that one foot of
snow for the
sierra mountains again
for us here with that the sierras there
that's going to swallow up all that
rainfall so as that atmospheric uber
starts to move this way downward
it will decrease even more and our
futurecast shows chances for showers
here
just not going to happen if we get
anything maybe we'll get some up in the
mountains in the form of showers and
here we're just going to get that cloud
cover that we're seeing overnight that's
not going to last all day tomorrow
though so here's your forecast 59
degrees increasing clouds overnight from
that system i just been pointed out to
you off the coast it'll be cool
overnight but with cloud cover it tends
to keep it a little bit mild overnight
so we'd be cool if we had clear skies
but now we're shooting for around 59 to
60 overnight 75 for tomorrow clouds in
the morning and then sun starts uh
increasing throughout the day tomorrow
so it's not going to be cloudy in the
whole day tomorrow breezy winds will
also increase so again we have breezy
winds outside right now we'll see those
winds increase tomorrow where those
gusts could get up to 25 to 30 tomorrow
highs neighborhood by neighborhood in
the mid 70s across the valley so
slightly cooler than today 73 centennial
hills 73 mountain zed 74 north las vegas
73 also for henderson outside the valley
we'll be at 72 for uh prompt and 74
boulder city tomorrow afternoon here's
your eight day forecast now after those
clouds tomorrow morning okay we're set
up for sunshine for the whole week look
at these numbers last week guys we were
in those 80s right low to mid 80s so
this time we're looking mid 70s high 70s
as we go to the weekend another
beautiful week
k.j
gorgeous november ted our